on this Monday night all hands on deck
Royal Canadian Air Force was able to get
hercules out to us
the relentless mission to rescue
Newfoundlanders and an impending crisis
over dwindling supplies there's no milk
and this is my turn stop
China's coronavirus outbreak the
scramble to contain a deadly illness
rapidly spreading from human to human
lung Wang Jo back in court the huawei
executives extradition hearing begins in
Vancouver plus royal family matters Will
and Kate's united front as Harry heads
back to Canada
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a big dig out underway in
Newfoundland tonight after that massive
storm it dumped so much snow on Friday
that much of the Northeast Avalon
Peninsula including the city of st.
John's is still paralyzed a state of
emergency remains in place that means
only snow clearing and emergency
vehicles are allowed on the roads people
cannot get around grocery stores and
most pharmacies are still closed and
everywhere people are digging 450
Canadian Forces soldiers and reservists
are now on the ground to shoveled in
hand the priority is getting to people
who can't get out of their homes Global
News was with them as they made their
way through the snow to shovel snow
bound Newfoundlanders out Ross Lord has
our top story before they could shovel
out stranded Newfoundlanders soldiers
had to dig themselves out as they set
out their priorities for how best to
pitch in we'll have snow removal for
seniors and those in need a critical
need of assistance we will transfer
people to warming centers as required
and we will also transport essential
employees to their workplace stage to
the right there are 175 reservists from
the area helping out along with
full-time soldiers like this team from
New Brunswick's Canadian Forces Base
gage town they wasted no time getting to
work the woman inside has been stranded
does anybody know that you're injured
yes so we made sure that she didn't need
any further medical attention and after
if the only thing that she required was
do a clearer doorway to make sure that
she could leave it or family members to
come in and check on it for some
outcomes are tragic this house in
Elliston near Bonavista was destroyed by
fire the occupants escaped safely but
emergency responders were powerless to
put it out the highway going up over
that Ridge was completely impassable so
of course our fire department our
emergency measures vehicles could not
reach the community of Ellison there's
still no sign of a man who went missing
at the height of Friday's blizzard 26
year-old Joshua wall left his home in
Roach's line to walk through the woods
to a friend's home in st. John's
authorities say the state of emergency
will remain in place until it's safe to
lift it residents are being told to
avoid buying gas unless they need it for
plowing snow or for household
emergencies it's an emergency around a
fuel line with most stores closed
available food supplies are becoming
scarce noting that they're only selling
gasoline and there's no milk and this is
my third stop on Tuesday all stores
selling basic foods are allowed to open
slow but steady progress no that's fine
we'll take care of it
Ross Lord global news the weather
networks Chris Murphy has been covering
this once-in-a-lifetime blizzard he's in
st. John's and I spoke to him earlier
hey Chris Newfoundlanders always make
the best of things I know but this
city's been paralyzed since Friday how
is the dig out going where you are long
continuous it just seems like it's going
on forever but I'll tell you something
Donna bad weather good people and people
are banding together to help each other
out because this would be too much for
any one person and of course the plows
are out the armed forces are here
anything to clean up this humongous mess
more snow fell overnight right Chris is
that it for now is Newfoundland going to
get a break yes the forecast looks good
it'll just get a little cold tonight I'm
worried some of the slush from this
morning may melt up curved a freeze up
could get a little bit icy but no storms
in the forecast so we'll have some
decent weather for the for the cleanup
to continue those snow banks lining the
streets behind you there can only go so
high I know people are shoveling
probably non-stop you can see them
behind you where are they going to put
all of that snow though that's being
cleared and piled up well that really is
the million-dollar question because
these pigs are just humongous well you
know that there's been we've been seeing
dump trucks going back and forth all
morning all day long they they leave
empty they come back full and a lot of
it is going into the harbor so they
lifted that ban because this is exten
awaiting circumstances so they're
putting a lot of it there otherwise it's
people just trying to band together
shovel it out and as you can see the
piles are getting higher and higher hey
Chris I know you've been you know
covering weather events for years a
couple of decades have you seen anything
like this in the middle of something
like this before no this is
unprecedented for me I mean I've done
floods and I've done even hurricane
durian in Nova Scotia and that was
something back in that September but not
only have I not seen anything like this
and I'm from Toronto but I'm talking to
battle-hardened Newfoundlanders who've
been here their whole lives and almost
every one of them are saying nope never
seen anything like this this is one for
the books and it's certainly one I'll
never forget
all right I'm sure a lot of people there
will remember it for the lifetime I
Chris from The Weather Network in st.
John's thanks so much there's a
development in a tragic story that
happened a year ago when bitter cold
gripped Montreal former Bloc Quebecois
leaders yield recep's 93 year old mother
died after being trapped outside her
seniors home and the family is now suing
the care home
Ln Raleigh a hot new set of hypothermia
a fire alarm went off in the middle of
the night at the looks governor building
in Montreal there was no fire but she
was stuck outside for nearly six hours
in minus 35 degree temperatures because
her access card wouldn't work and nobody
noticed she was missing a coroner ruled
her death was accidental the family says
it was avoidable human being a human
being it's not a bank account but when
you're paying a lot you hope at at least
when they're advertising that the
rendered that great kind of services and
it's not a case well it's shocking the
Doucet family is seeking 1.25 million
dollars in damages from the seniors home
the family announced last July they were
prepared to take legal action if the
residents did not respond there is an
alarming development tonight in the
outbreak of a new SARS like respiratory
illness first detected in China
officials there now confirm the corona
virus has been spread from human to
human
the
cases of the pneumonia like virus were
detected last month and over the weekend
the number of cases soared extending to
Japan South Korea and Thailand and at
least three people have died here in
Canada three people were suspected of
having it but this afternoon that was
ruled out as Heather Eurex west reports
the chief public health officer warns
this is a virus that could spread
rapidly concern about the spread of a
new SARS like illness is building across
many Chinese cities this week as the
country prepares to ring in the Lunar
New Year yes it will impact my plans
during Chinese New Year this college
student says because the virus could
spread faster in crowded places what
began with a handful of cases linked to
a seafood market in central China last
month is spreading at an alarming pace
Chinese health officials confirmed
Monday the virus is now spreading
through human contact I think it's
really an indication that this is not
likely to be contained sort of the
genies out of the bottle if you will
this Toronto based company uses
artificial intelligence and advanced
data analytics to track emerging health
threats it first became aware of the new
corona virus outbreak in China on New
Year's Eve since then it's been looking
at international air travel patterns to
predict how the disease could spread we
actually did publish some of this work
in the Journal of travel medicine
looking at the anticipated spread across
the region I mean in fact many of the
cities at the top of our list have now
been affected around 200 cases have been
reported where the virus first appeared
in Wuhan but there have also been cases
confirmed in Beijing Shanghai and Wan
dong province as well as in South Korea
Japan and Thailand the World Health
Organization announced Monday that an
emergency committee has been formed to
determine whether the outbreak
constitutes a public health emergency of
international concern the outbreak
already shares a number of similarities
to the deadly SARS outbreak that left 44
Canadians dead in 2003 it's not yet
known just how dangerous this new form
of coronavirus will be so far at least
three people have died Canada's chief
public health officer says given the
number of people who travel between
China and Canada cases of the new corona
virus here are not unexpected provincial
health authorities have been told to be
on alert for possible cases
and new signs and screening measures
will be in place at the Vancouver
Toronto and Montreal airports in the
coming days so far though no Canadians
have become ill with the virus either
here or abroad
Heather Erik's West Global News Calgary
more than a year after she was taken
into custody at Vancouver International
Airport the daughter of the founder of
Huawei has begun her court battle to
fight extradition to the US mung Wong so
the CFO of the Chinese telecom giant was
in BC Supreme Court today the case is a
complex mix of global politics
technology and allegations of fraud as
Robin Gill reports her lawyers accused
Canada of doing dirty work for the u.s.
dressed in designer duds and
accessorized with the GPS ankle bracelet
the millionaire CFO of Huawei offered a
smile and wave as she entered court
there were supporters and opponents
ready to greet her the international
attention on mangwon show has been
intense because she's so famous to
prominence it's a bit like Bill Gates
being arrested in China monk is accused
of using a subsidiary telecommunications
company sky comm to sell American
computer equipment to Iran which is a
violation of US sanctions against the
Islamic Republic and that she used
American banks to do this business
further putting them at risk of fraud
but her defense team is highlighting two
key dates that the alleged offences
happened in 2013 but the arrest warrant
wasn't issued until 2016 when Canada
didn't have the same sanctions
ultimately the court must decide if
monks case meets the double criminality
requirement that is the alleged offenses
must be crimes in both Canada and the US
for the extradition to proceed I see
this going in the direction of
an acquittal from his man that acquittal
is at the crux of what could happen to
two Canadians Michael Kovac and Michael
SPAWAR who were detained in Beijing
accused of spying widely seen as a quid
pro quo after mungs arrest in 2018 at
Vancouver International Airport the two
men are political prisoners caught in
the middle and what is amounted to a
trade war between China and the US but
this political scientist says there can
be no prisoner swap and that mungs case
has to go through Canada's justice
system before the men can be released
the issue of you know treating the two
Michaels as hostage and doing a swap is
very difficult to accept for Canadians
right this is now how it works we have a
rule of law system little consolation
for kovorix wife who was attending the
extradition hearing she declined to
comment on her husband's year-long
detention a Canadian representative for
the companies out there proceedings and
issued this statement via Twitter we
trust in Canada's judicial system which
will prove miss monks innocence so monk
is under house arrest after posting 10
million dollars in bail and has millions
more to fight the long legal battle
Robin Gill Global News Vancouver
Canada's federal cabinet ministers are
all in Winnipeg tonight they're holding
a three-day retreat they're choosing to
meet in a western province was
deliberate the Prime Minister and his
Deputy Prime Minister Chrystia Freeland
are intent on building bridges in
provinces where they have plenty of
political enemies Abigail Beeman reports
Winnipeg gateway to the West with a
premier who could act as a bridge
between Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
and more hostile Western leaders well
I'm not a wek Syd fan I think I'd made
that pretty clear Manitoba premier Brian
Pallister says he's open to
reconsidering a carbon tax something
Manitoba is currently suing the feds
over but he's looking for respect in
return I want respect from Ottawa for
the fact that Manitoba has an incredible
green record look we're eliminating
single-use plastic bags we eliminated
cool it has cost my farm thousands of
dollars farmer William Pallister is with
the Western Canadian Wheat Growers
Association and also happens to be a
nephew of the premier he says the carbon
tax is his biggest
CERN and Western alienation is very real
he's disappointed the Agriculture
Minister isn't meeting with farming
groups like his on this trip the results
of the election were determined before
Manitoba's votes are even in so it does
seem like our voice isn't being heard
and it seems like almost leaning towards
Western self government is actually
being discussed in the coffee shops
since re-election Deputy Prime Minister
Krista Freeland has been spending a lot
of time in the West listening to
concerns our first priority needs to be
let's look for where the common ground
is let's look for where we can work
together to advance the national
interest a promise to listen hard but
nothing concrete and I don't think
you're going to see public opinion in
Alberta's shift until we do see
something concrete we hear word salad
about listening and consultation and
collaboration all very good words but in
when it comes down to action they seem
to ignore the people whose lives are
affected by many of their policies one
thing that will help the Liberals
especially in Alberta progress on the
trans mountain pipeline we're currently
estimating mid to late 22 for completion
and I hope it does you know as you said
change the temperature somewhat Tuesday
cabinet will hear from more Westerners
at a session led by Special
Representative to the prairies Jim Carr
but what concrete actions liberals plan
to take on this file remains to be seen
with the house set to resume next week
Abigail Beeman Global News Winnipeg the
pro-gun rally that triggered a state of
emergency coming up thousands fight for
the right to bear arms
you
thousands of pro-gun advocates many of
them armed have converged on a state
capitol in the American state of
Virginia they're opposed to a series of
new gun control measures being
considered by the state legislature
the rally attracted gun owners from
across the country hoping to head off
any trouble the governor declared a
state of emergency before it even
started and seven alleged white
supremacists including a Canadian were
arrested last week
Jackson prosecco explains what happened
armed and angry they marched on
Virginia's State Capitol gun owners who
believe they're on the verge of losing
their rights of bear arms I don't think
there should be any regulations on our
Second Amendment shall not be infringed
is there for a reason I carry with me
every day I feel safe that way I am a
single female and I I think it makes a
big difference and in my life more than
22 thousand marchers came to Richmond
many from across America united we stand
and I'll stand with these awesome people
here believing the state's proposed gun
laws requiring background checks and
limiting buyers to one handgun purchase
per month could mark the beginning of
the end of the Second Amendment in the
US the laws were proposed in the wake of
a mass shooting in the state that killed
12 last year with this whack these
wackadoodle laws it's just gonna go
across the country days before the rally
officials grew concerned that the event
had been co-opted by neo-nazis seven
suspected white nationalists were
arrested last week including former
Canadian Army reservist Patrick Matthews
police worried they planned a violent
disruption like the deadly 2017 clash in
Charlottesville while President Donald
Trump amped up the fears of Gun Owners
tweeting this is just the beginning
don't let it happen vote Republican in
2020
whether you like guns or you don't like
guns you can't take air rights in the
end the march on Richmond stayed
peaceful but offered a preview of a
tense election year ahead with gun
control a trigger issue for voters on
both sides
Jackson cross Co Global News
a head from wildfires to flash floods
the latest wild weather to hammer
Australia you are watching global
national this is what's happening in
Australia now golf ball-sized hail
stones hammered the same areas that were
devastated by wildfires the hail hit
hard in Canberra the nation's capital
and in Melbourne and Sydney damaging
cars punching holes and rooms and
ripping branches from trees and in
central New South Wales there are dust
storms gusts over 90 kilometers an hour
reported as walls of dust blew across
some communities the weather change
provided some relief from the
devastating wildfires but authorities
warned drier conditions and warmer
temperatures are coming back in the days
ahead
rescue efforts have been called off for
seven climbers missing after an
avalanche in Nepal fresh snow slides of
preventing crews from looking for the
four South Koreans and three local
guides they disappeared on Friday about
200 other climbers were rescued by
helicopter over the weekend the initial
Avalanche was believed to have been
triggered by heavy rain and snow along a
popular trekking route at the base of
Mount Annapurna next the mixed reactions
on Harry and Megan as they prepare for
their royal exit
the royal family is getting on with
business without Harry Prince William
hosted his first solar reception at
Buckingham Palace tonight his wife Kate
the Duchess of Cambridge was by his side
but his brother was not Prince Harry is
reportedly on his way back to Canada to
join his wife Megan and son Archie who
are stepping away from official roles in
the royal family
Prince Harry says what happens next is a
leap of faith his grandmother the Queen
is boss and she's decided there's no way
Harry and Megan can be part-time Royals
they will not be able to use the title
Royal Highness anymore and they are
giving up access to public funds Redman
Shannon has reaction to the Royal
withdrawal a man looking to escape
public attention under more scrutiny
than ever before
Prince Harry appearing in public the
morning after a speech that was years in
the making it brings me great sadness
that it has come to this the decision
that I have made for my wife and I to
step back is not one I made lightly our
hope was to continue serving the Queen
the Commonwealth and my military
associations but without public funding
unfortunately that wasn't possible after
their deal with the Queen was announced
on Saturday Harry and Megan willed
neither server directly nor will they
escape public funding well Harry has
said he doesn't want to receive any
public funds but his security is
publicly funded and that's very
expensive
we know that overall the cost of funding
the security of the royal family is over
a hundred million pounds a year now if a
Harry alone it could well be three to
five million pounds how the Canadian and
British taxpayers share that bill has
yet to be decided I have a lot of
sympathy for the couple I don't have
much sympathy for the royal family
I think they've got lots of money mixed
reactions from Britons in London and
from Canadian tourists she's taking him
away from his family and that's never a
good sign I think this is it's like a
bit crazy that it's getting this much
like publicity when there's like bigger
things happening in the world I
understand that because of what he went
through with his mom yes
so young and and what happened Prince
Harry is now reportedly left for Canada
to be with Megan and their son Archie no
doubt happy to be out of the spotlight
again and to start a new chapter of his
life
one that could reshape the royal family
for years to come
Donna Redman Shannon in London thanks
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's your
Canada is cross river in sheva equal but
we'd love to see your Canada please
email it to viewers at global national
calm thanks for watching and I hope to
see you here again
tomorrow bye bye
[Music]